“It began Saturday morning with
a massive rocket barrage
from Gaza striking across Israel.”
In the early hours of Saturday, October 7th...
Israelis in the south of the country...
huddled in basements and bomb shelters.
They listened as Hamas militants
went house to house in their neighborhoods...
brutally killing civilians of all ages
and taking hostages.
These homes were in communities
just a few miles from this border
with Gaza...
where for two decades
the Israeli army has guarded this wall...
which holds more than 2 million Palestinians
in what's been called
an open-air prison.
Little water.
Little electricity.
Virtually no way out.
Hiding in fear.
Israelis texted their
friends and family
a very similar question.
Where is the army?
Israel is one of the biggest military spenders
in proportion to its population.
That coupled with billions in military aid
from the US
has made the Israeli military
one of the most advanced in the world.
We have planes. We have helicopters.
We have tanks.
We have everything.
For the first couple of hours, it's like we have no army.
“The words of survivors...”
“Where was the army?”
You can see the strength of Israel's military
in its response to the Hamas attacks.
Persistent bombing in Gaza,
leveling neighborhoods
killing more than 2000 people,
including at least 700 children.
Preparing for a ground invasion.
But on the day of the Hamas attacks
in Israel.
At the sites of some of the worst violence...
soldiers didn't arrive for about 8 hours.
By then, hundreds were dead,
missing, or kidnaped.
Why did it take so long?
To answer that question,
we need to look here:
In the West Bank.
In 1947, this entire area
was home to nearly 2 million people.
The vast majority of them Palestinian Muslims
and Christians.
When World War II ended in the wake of
the Holocaust in Europe...
the newly formed United Nations voted
to divide this land into two states:
A Jewish state and an Arab state...
with Jerusalem as a separate
UN-controlled entity.
But in 1948 zionist militias and paramilitary groups
carried out
a mass expulsion and massacre of Palestinians...
seizing their villages to expand
the Jewish state.
Then, in 1967, after a war
with its Arab neighbors...
Israel occupied the West Bank, East Jerusalem,
and the Gaza Strip
taking more land designated for Palestinians.
And started turning parts of those
Palestinian territories
into illegal settlements for Jewish Israelis.
Today, the most extensive examples of that
can be found here:
In the West Bank...
where some of the settlements
have gotten so big
they've achieved city status.
And they're just some of the hundreds of settlements
in the occupied West Bank
that have been built on land
originally intended for a Palestinian state.
And where Palestinians still live...
under Israeli military rule...
with far fewer rights than their Israeli neighbors.
From the very earliest beginnings
of Netanyahu's career in politics
he's been an opponent
of the two state solution...
been in the central part of his ideology.
And it is just intimately bound up
in his idea
of what Israel is.
That it needs to have control
of the West Bank.
“Israel must retain the overriding
security control
over the entire area west
of the Jordan River.”
The government has encouraged
settlements in the West Bank
like the one advertised here.
“Home of your dreams.”
“The tranquility of a picturesque
setting and crisp mountain air...
with all the benefits and amenities
that Jerusalem has to offer.”
Enormous resources
have been devoted to this project.
And this is bipartisan to put it
in American terms.
This is a state project.
They are funding them.
They're paving roads for them.
They're providing security for them.
They're creating infrastructure
and water and electricity for them.
Tax breaks to incentivize Israelis to move there.
The number of Israeli Jewish settlers
in the West Bank
began growing before Netanyahu
came to power in 1996...
and continued even when he was
out of office from 2000 to 2009.
But if you look at the number of
new settlement outposts each year...
you can see that there's
a noticeable gap right here.
Under international pressure...
those new outposts were halted.
But after Netanyahu came back to power...
his government started legalizing
some of those old settlements.
And at the same time, they built
and promoted new ones.
As this map shows, they've proliferated
ever since.
This is a project of slow-motion colonization.
So what you have is Palestinians
living in these tiny little pockets
these little urban islands of control.
And so when you look at the West Bank...
what you see is that more than 60% of it
is under full Israeli control
and administration.
And that's where the more sparsely populated
Palestinian communities are
that are slowly being forcibly transferred.
The United Nations put out a report...
saying that since the beginning of 2022...
more than 1,100 Palestinian Bedouins
have been forcibly transferred from
their communities in the West Bank.
In the founding statute of
the International Criminal Court
there is a section defining war crimes.
The transfer, directly or indirectly
by the occupying power of parts of
its own civilian population
into the territory it occupies.
Or the deportation or transfer of all
or parts of the population
of the occupied territory
within or outside this territory.
It's part of the reason why the United Nations
has called the Israeli settlements...
unlawful under international law.
But Salem, a Jerusalem-based nonprofit...
has documented numerous instances
of violence
against Palestinians in the West Bank.
Israeli settlers have attacked
Palestinian houses with stones...
torched cars...
vandalized a supermarket
and burned homes.
According to other reports
the Israeli military has killed
hundreds of Palestinians
in a series of violent events
this year alone.
The deal with Israelis is, we will live
in these dangerous places...
and you, the army, will protect us.
So at that point settlement enterprise necessitates
the misallocation of military resources.
Those were the military resources
that were missing
when Hamas broke through
the border with Gaza.
There were empty posts
on the border there.
Troops weren't getting the proper
security notifications.
It was clear that the entire system...
for monitoring...
what was happening on the Gaza border
had broken down.
There is a real ground swell
among the Israeli population that
this was just an immense disaster
presided over by Netanyahu.
And in the West Bank,
trying to colonize it
and seize Palestinian lands...
that you devoted resources and attention
to those initiatives...
at the expense of protecting us
from Hamas.
“We have to go immediately.”
“Immediately.”
“He is a murderer.”
“We’re all very, very frustrated
that he's still there.”
A recent poll found that four out of five
Jewish Israelis
believe the government and Prime Minister Netanyahu
are to blame for the attacks.
More than half say he should resign
when the war is over.
Netanyahu really has been
the architect
of Israel's long term strategy towards Gaza.
That's happened under his administration.
He thought that he could contain Hamas
deter it from doing the worst stuff.
Periodically fight with them in ways
that would not hurt very many
Israeli civilians...
and encourage division between
Hamas and the West Bank...
to make sure that the Palestinians
could not make
a more credible case for a peace agreement.
That policy has just...
it's an obvious failure at this point.